continuing our team coverage tonight we
are also tracking a deadly crash
involving a motorcycle in the southwest
valley
this happened at blue diamond and
lindell madison kimbrough joins us live
on the scene
with the latest developments tonight
madison
yes a very busy day as this marks the
third fatality within the last
24 hours that's according to nevada
highway patrol
now take a look at the scene from
earlier this fatal motorcycle crash
happened around 12
30 this afternoon when a black yamaha
sports bike collided with a truck
instantly killing the motorcyclist the
driver of the blue f-150 truck
was unharmed and stayed on scene the
motorcyclist hit the bed of the truck
just missing the passenger side the
truck was attempting a left turn
and the motorcycle was heading eastbound
to the high rate of speed and as you can
see
from the damage on the f-150 that we're
talking of a very violent collision
lindell is currently open to blue
diamond road an eastbound blue diamond
has also reopened
this marks the eighth fatal accident and
tenth death since the start
of the year we are told that speed is
determined to be a factor in this crash
it's still unknown the name and age of
the motorcyclist we do know that it was
a man
but of course we will keep you updated
throughout the evening on 8 news now
and online at 8 news now dot com
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now